hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome another
edition of ask Evan in today's episode
I'm going to answer question from one of
my forum readers Marilyn who was us him
but a website that she's working on
called renegade millionaire videos and
wanted my advice so I thought it'd be
easier to do a screencast here so we can
follow along on the screen so I loaded
up Marilyn's website here and it's a
video series from Dan Kennedy sharing
strategies of how to make money in a
down economy so overall this website is
is pretty simple not a lot to it it it's
great in that hits on a point that I
think a lot of people can relate to
which is you know making money in a down
economy a lot of people have been laid
off or having a hard time with their
business and so that's that's a touch
point that I think would hit home with a
lot of people it's got a dramatic kind
of over-the-top video here that just
says some of the things you're going to
learn in the video series and there's a
you know simple sign up box here just
first name last name email and it's free
so not a lot that you're asking for and
all people have to do is leave their
name and email to kind of get access to
the course in terms of some suggestions
the first thing is talk a little bit
more go who dan kennedy is you know
you're making an assumption that people
know who dan kennedy is and while some
people might a lot of people will have
no idea who he is so there's not a lot
of information on Dan Kennedy a little
bit lower you say he's a marketing
legend and then a little bit below it
says he's been marketing for 35 years
helping clients generate more than a
billion dollars in sales so this has
really low down on the page they're
talking about who Dan Kennedy is unless
you're only targeting people who know
who dan kennedy is then you know this
would be great for them but I think
you'd want to reach a much wider
audience so assuming most people don't
really know who he is I put his picture
on there I'd say the types of clients he
works with so I'll gelling a billion
dollars in revenue he could be working
with big companies and that could have
nothing to do with my entrepreneurial
business so show that he worked with you
know smaller entrepreneurs start up
businesses people
you know a little bit of revenue and
growing show the types of results that
he's been able to generate for people
because just saying that you know 35
years in the business isn't really going
to convince a lot of people to want to
sign up for so have his picture tell
little bit more about his background in
the video I have him I'm assuming he's a
great speaker if there's a whole video
series on him so show him in the video
series instead of the clouds and a
dramatic music and then show some of the
people that he's worked with so to tag
along with that I'd also show some
testimonials right there's nothing here
that says watching this video series has
changed my life and I've grow my
business five hundred percent or
whatever it is so you got to get the
testimonials on there you have to have
this true stories include their pictures
include links to their websites so that
people can feel like they're signing up
to something that's worth a lot of money
now it is free so you know you're not
asking people to give you a lot of money
up front but still people will think
before they leave the name and email
address so the more you can do convince
them that this is going to work their
time the better and testimonials will
help them you know some of these points
here are good weather recession is your
gold ticket it's a statement that you
know a lot of people would you know
potentially disagree with so it's a bold
statement that would catch some interest
I didn't get this one be rewarded for
multiple committed relationships I don't
know really what that means and why it's
such a big headline if you had this why
the recession is your golden ticket that
might draw a lot more attention than
something like be rewarded for multiple
committed relationships so just
something to think about you know
obviously your headlines are really
important and generating interest for
the four people sign up for your list
and then the last thing is I was driven
to this website because Marilyn is an
active member of my form so she's pretty
new to the farms and within a week
posted over 20 posts here and is adding
value to the membership and so I'm
curious now who is this Marilyn person
what is Maryland's website and what can
I do to help Marilyn and when I click on
the website there's no mention of
Maryland so I'd love to see something
here about who Marilyn is and you know
what value you bring to this and why you
believe that this is a great opportunity
or not because people who are reading
your messages are curious to learn more
about what you're doing what you're up
to so if you're going to be continuing
to act the active in forums and get on
blogs and and be part of the community
for entrepreneurs and add a lot of great
content which you've done you have just
you haven't just been promoting you put
on some great content to the forms
people going to want to know a little
bit more about you and what you do so
I'd have here you know your own personal
message maybe your own video if you can
do it as well as to why you think this
is a great opportunity and I think the
people who visit the site from your
forum links and other communities that
you're involved in will convert on a
much higher level than just having this
which looks like an affiliate type of
page without any kind of customization
from your own it so I hope that helps
Marilyn if you guys liked the video
please give it a thumbs up but I'd love
to hear what you have to think about
this website good bad and ugly if you
want to leave a comment under the video
and stay tuned for next episode